you want to keep spending you want to
keep growing
but the more you spend the the the
higher the risk for a lower
profit margin is and you want to show
your investors
uh a high profit margin welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
let's talk about marketing and gaming
meet the iran bertal
vp of growth sciplay corporation iran's
interest in marketing began 15 years ago
while researching a mcdonald's case
study
in 2010 he joined matami and four years
later
founded his own company with two great
friends he later joined apister
and spearheaded the entire business and
media operations he recently joined
sciplay as social gaming behemoth
as vp growth and is looking after their
global marketing efforts starting from
organic and paid user acquisition
to marketing tech art and innovation
javon bertal welcome to 20 minute
leaders from the sci play offices i
believe right
absolutely thank you for having me yeah
up in the 25th floor
and uh
wonderful having you here uh vice
president of growth at
sciplay corporation and we're going to
talk about gaming and marketing and your
own trajectory and journey
and you know the gaming industry is you
know growing
like crazy and this whole question of
growth
and you know it's become more and more
fascinating for me especially
and seeing it in different industries
and i'm excited to pick your brain on
how you think through growth
and what are some of the interesting
challenges that you're dealing with but
but even before then was it always
obvious to you that you're going to be
in marketing through different
organizations and through
you know growth that this was sort of
the big plan
well it was definitely kind of the plan
from the get-go i couldn't tell you that
that things hadn't changed along the way
but
um initially when you look back about 15
years ago
it's definitely something that i wanted
to do and so
what is it about you know when you say
something i wanted to do so when you
look at marketing or growth
what do you see what what is the thing
that excites you about that
well that's a good question i i think
it's uh it's kind of a blend of
of um of a lot of different elements so
uh
we're obviously talking about um the
the unique skill of kind of uh
persuading
consumers to consume your your product
your or your service right and
that's a that's an art uh of some sort
if you think about it and
uh i i think kind of the the secret
sauce to marketing is
is kind of understanding who uh who who
the target audience is and
and kind of pinpointing that target
audience with with a very precise
messaging
and if you get that wrong then it's it's
just uh
it just goes downhill from there right
so you you really gotta
gotta understand what you're doing you
have to kind of set the objectives
and and make sure that you're on the
right path from the get-go
so just as a case study sciplay
corporation
how do you go about figuring out target
audience
you know matrix how do you actually you
know communicate with that target
audience what is sort of the
the game that you're that you're playing
with your team over there
so society has been around for for
decades now right as
kind of a subsidiary of scientific games
so we pretty know we pretty much know
what we're we're dealing with
but things have changed so rapidly as as
you mentioned uh during
the past year or so and it's a whole
different
ballgame right now so the i i guess that
the major challenge that we face
currently is kind of um challenging our
our predefined assumptions so we we know
who our users are right we we have the
data
um uh like we can tell who the users are
up
by their facebook profile um
they they they disclose that information
happily because then we can target them
with custom events and and offerings and
and incentives and
whether it's our vip clients um
or or any other um end user looking to
to play our games right so basically um
while we thought for for quite a quite a
bit quite a long time we were
sure that our very specific target
audience is as of a specific gender
and a specific age group um it has
become
more and more clear that uh that the
industry has
has changed right that more users are
are
playing um a lot of games not only for
kind of the
the core features but a lot of users are
also looking for kind of the meta games
the social aspects of the games um
playing together um
playing playing solely but also but
at the end of the day we're looking at a
whole new target audience that
that we can approach like you have these
huge games
that you even forget what their core
offering is
right that's regained that have this
huge meta going on and
we're just trying to understand um
how to kind of place ourselves in our
marketing endeavors
within that new landscape it reminds me
a little bit of
this apple tv series mythic quest uh
which uh which is hilarious and one end
but
it's also it shows me perspective of the
gaming world where
really you're creating a whole new
universe and all of a sudden people are
doing
your users are are doing things that you
didn't expect them to do and you have to
now shift your mindset of okay so i
guess that today's
15 year olds aren't the same as you know
three years ago
15 year olds right that things are
changing so rapidly
absolutely things have changed so much
in the past decades i mean i'm
i i i feel 60 but i'm only 38
so uh so so it's uh that's what kids do
to you
but um at the end of the day i i
remember i remember days where where
consumer behavior and and uh things like
that that
were totally different than they are
today um right
like today we have today we have one of
our one of our products is is kind of a
focused on on under the sea right and
then and fish and and the ocean and
things like that so
we're looking on a marketing perspective
on how to tie that
up with things like that you see on
netflix today like conspiracy
right how to kind of turn that into save
the ocean and
and stop polluting and so that's a whole
new thing that we didn't even think
about 20 or 30 years
now tell me a little bit about you know
organic versus paid growth i don't know
much about it i'm really curious
especially when it comes to the gaming
world
what what what is the differentiation
and then
what are sort of the pros and cons as
you see them
um well well they kind of both fit in um
uh perfectly and and blend perfectly
together i think there's no such
such thing as as kind of um
or organic growth as opposed to a paid
growth
right you're looking at at the end of
the day at a user acquisition and you
need to understand that you you
what you want to do is you want to
increase the user database
and and at the end of the day either you
target those users
through digital means that are that are
paid
and these can be traditional uh facebook
uh
google search uh influencer marketing
things like that
but it can also be to kind of target
those same users
uh through organic means whether it's
app store optimization and to kind of
make sure that
you have your users um exposed
to to your products and and that your
your products are ranked
up there and and those two blend
really well together um to kind of
create
uh a very holistic view of uh
of of our whole user base like today if
i need to
think of the distribution then we're
definitely talking about something like
a 50 50 split
between oh wow organic and paid users
so yeah and organic is also a very
strong
um tool that you have to uh
to to base your international footprint
right whereas
it's pretty difficult to do that with
with a paid
kind of a paid initiative it's super
easy to see that hey
we have a bunch of users coming in from
france
let's tackle that market and understand
their their incentive
right and so i i did hear a lot of this
concept that you know organic
is considered more valuable a user that
came organically is more valuable than a
user that came in
through paid paid endeavors is that is
that really the case
why is that that a lot of people think
that a pa
an organic user is worth more well first
of all it's uh
i mean if you don't look at each user
individually as but you look at it as a
whole
it definitely makes sense right if if
you go and you open up your browser and
you search for one of sciplay's games
then you'll be you'll have a much higher
intent
to to play to proceed in the game and
even to
uh to to make a purchase right then if
you were to see
like a cyplay ad on facebook or or on
the open web
or one of your other apps and then you'd
be like hey this looks like a neat game
i'd love to download it and give it a
shot but it's not something that he
actively
uh pursued so it's it's a it's a
different different ballgame and we
we definitely look at those two kind of
on a separate scale
with a different lifetime value
so as you are now sitting in the
position of vice president of growth at
siteplay and you're mentioning that this
is a you know a corporation
many many years a lot of expertise in
the field you you know already a lot of
your target audience it is shifting and
you are
and it sounds like you're keeping up
with the shifts and you're and you're
continuously questioning you know are we
still doing the right thing
what is the challenge then what where
where are you headed from here
at this point when you know vp growth
games are exploding around us what what
is your sort of
task in this big ship yeah that's that's
a great question i i think that uh where
you headed from here is kind of the
tagline for every vp growth right
because you you really want to kind of
steer the ship in the right direction
not only in terms of
how to grow our kind of our digital
marketing
efforts but how to grow the company um
because because you have to work in sync
with
the game studios to understand what
their roadmap
uh looks like so you can kind of sync
that into your
uh into the marketing roadmap and then
you can kind of understand that we're
all
going in the in the right direction
right you have to work with the guys
from business development and strategy
to understand what the m a targets are
because the m a targets are very very
influential on on growth and
and also have an impact on what our
marketing roadmap will look like
so basically what you need to do
is first of all understand you have to
work your way from the top to the bottom
you got to understand
where the company is is headed um so the
company
scipla was was publicly offered in
may of 2019 so it's been only two years
right and and that's a very
a fairly low uh low amount of time and
well we had all these kind of uh
objective shifts
um to where we want to be and where we
want to go and right now
our aim is to kind of protect our
enterprise value
and to increase that and to grow month
over month and quarter over quarter and
how do you do that right because
you want to keep spending you want to
keep growing
but the more you spend the the the
higher the risk for a lower
profit margin is and you want to show
your investors
uh a high profit margin so they want to
see growth
and they want to see you cut costs and
they want to see you
just just basically get it all done
uh right it's it's a difficult task but
i i guess the the key here is to kind of
make sure that you work your way to
understand the objectives first of all
on the high level
and then downstream them to the
departments and
and the teams and at the end of the day
understand
what the the ua manager does
to contribute to the objectives of the
company
and and around how many people are you
at sciplay
so currently we're we're about 600
strong uh
about 400 people are based in uh uh
in the us uh in two main two main
locations so cedar falls iowa and austin
texas
and then we got about 200 more here in
tel aviv and if i'm not mistaken i think
about
about 80 to 90 people out of the 200
here
were actually uh recruited doing
covid so yeah wow pretty cute
now i'm asking this because now i'm
saying okay so you have 600 people
an expectation to grow month over month
to cut costs to be innovative
you're tasked with trying to you know
comprehend how
the hell are we keeping up with this
ever changing world how do we remain
relevant especially as gaming i'm
assuming that gaming is one of the most
is one of the industries that is
transforming the fastest and in the
greatest extent
because uh there's there's just so much
money in there and there's so many now
players and
and it's all about creativity right so
how do you balance creativity and risk
taking
with being a vp at an enterprise that at
the end has investors
and you can't just go and you know and
and and fail
right you have to show results
right i mean the gaming market is so
over flooded right you've got
literally millions of of apps available
in in the big stores and
the i guess the the the hardest part is
to
um remain kind of
attractive enough for your loyal user
base to
not want to churn and to kind of go to
to
uh to other con to other competitors
because i guess um
when you look at cyprus games right
we're kind of we have our
our our unique selling points and our
value propositions but it's
it's in no way um
something unique uh in the market right
you got you got big companies
uh like platika and you got companies
like um aristocrat product madness and
and moon active in those guys and they
all have great products
and what causes the user
to remain loyal in our kind in in our
uh safe helm rather than kind of uh
switching switching sides and i think
the answer to that is is content
right we want to make sure and and
that's kind of
that's the main challenge that the game
teams face today right
they have to keep content booming new
features
um incentives uh a great economy
um retargeting efforts that we're
helping out with
uh in in in the marketing side and
uh and and customer success and and vip
um kind of special attention and things
like that
you got to make sure that um
that you're keeping your closest
players um at your side that's key
and so how involved are you with the
actual
gaming industry are you a gamer yourself
do you actually go and participate
in in the thinking process behind the
products that you're building or or
are you more siloed into okay these are
the products of the company
and how how do we grow these products
within the market
which which of these two or balances
well basically i'm a gamer but i'm a
gamer by heart uh
it's something that i i've been very
passionate about
uh since i was a kid uh back in the
arcades and then i had
i bought my first nintendo back in 1980
something when i was
wow years old like five years old um
but i've always uh had a strong affinity
um for for games and kind when the when
the smartphones came
came along and you could download games
for free i mean
that's crazy right the whole concept of
freemium was just mind-blowing
and and yeah so it's definitely
something that i've showed a lot of
interest in
um and and i'm a hardcore fan
of of uh of some mobile apps today of
some some gaming apps today which i
deposit uh quite a bit each month so so
i'm a good user too
um i actually i hadn't
i i didn't spend the majority of my
career with gaming
the actually i went i went to a
different direction of ad monetization
uh which was kind of uh indirectly
related or correlated to uh to the
gaming industry but
um that's what i've been doing for like
about about
a decade or so the last decade and and
and then i kind of i saw the surge
during kovid and that was kind of the
tipping point for me
uh it's something that i always wanted
to do but i
i just i waited for like great
opportunity in the right company
and and this was kind of like uh the
perfect opportunity for me and and i
feel myself
uh incredibly lucky and and fortunate to
be here
i love that and you know if you have to
you know guess if
gaming in five or ten years paint me a
picture
of how how that looks like in your mind
the gaming world
oh wow um so i i think in in in a matter
of five to ten years
so much could change like we could be
like
we're we're looking at at the
technological advancements of things
like
uh like virtual reality and and
augmented reality and things like that
it could be a whole different
uh industry and landscape and and you
know we could be talking about
um like a a different way to play games
like uh i i just saw
a post today by by mark zuckerberg
showing how he plays beat saber
right and and that's not you should look
that up it's it's a good post
he's actually not bad but that's
definitely a whole new
uh aspect of gaming that we're not like
accustomed to
if you ask how will users consume
games in in five or ten years then i'm
just
i'm just seeing the chart just just
blast off right i'm
i'm i'm in no way do i think that we're
going to see
some kind of uh of stagnation or
or decline i just think that we're going
to see
a lot of a lot of interesting trends
coming in mainly
from from asia and apec i think that's
where it's at
wow
this was wonderful i have a three
questions they're not about gaming
they're not about marketing they're
they're about your own
are you ready for them let's do it
let's do it we'll start off with your
favorite subject
in middle school or high school
uh i'd have to go with physics i
actually i i majored in physics in high
school i love physics
okay astronomy and astronomy geek as
well i just love how
how the everything works out uh
perfectly and and how the world works
that's pretty geeky i know but i just
love it
amazing uh who would be a role model or
something
somebody that that creates an
inspiration for you
on some level i i'd have to go a bit
cliche on this
and say say my father which is also a
bit emotional for me as he he passed
away a few years ago
from cancer but he the reason i'm
mentioning him is because he was the one
who actually
drove me to um to found my own company
and and
decades earlier to just just start
working on my own
and and be more assertive and have that
confident i needed to kind of
uh pave my my my path and in the
beginning of my career so uh
definitely him amazing and
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
i'd go with a passionate
experimental and a growth seeker
passionate experimental and growth
seeker iran
this was wonderful best of luck with
sciplay corporations
i think that it's a fascinating position
i have no idea
how it begins and ends but it sounds
incredibly fascinating
and and i'm sure that we only you know
scratched the surface right now but but
i'm excited to learn more and more
throughout the year so thank you very
much for this and stay safe and stay
healthy
my pleasure mikhail thank you so much
bye bye bye